- This tastes like the sweet beginning
of the end of my diet.
(light music)
Hey guys, I'm Brenda, I'm a Tasty producer
and today we will be comparing
homemade versus store bought Twinkies.
I need to know if we can
duplicate this cake at home
and make it taste even better.
Let's get cooking.
Twinkies are known for its fluffiness,
which is why we tested a
variety of cake batter recipes
that would give us that
airy, bouncy texture
typical of Twinkies.
The conclusion, lots of egg
whites and a mix of flours.
As for the egg whites,
you wanna whisk this
with a hand mixer until you
get soft peaks like this one.
Cute!
(chimes sound)
We are including egg yolks
because it really gives the batter
an irresistible flavor and that
really pretty, golden color
that makes Twinkies so appealing.
Earlier I mentioned the
use of various flours.
We're actually adding cake flour
because it is lighter and adds fluffiness,
and all-purpose flour just
to add a little density
which should give us a
cake that is not too heavy,
not too airy, it would
just be like Twinkies.
(light music)
Because you wanna preserve
your air-bubble population
to keep the fluffiness factor strong,
you wanna gently fold the batter to mix it
and definitely do not stir full speed.
We're adding a little
butter and milk mixture
for flavor and texture.
You see, the butter
adds a little tenderness
which is definitely
what we're looking for.
Let's add a little vanilla,
because what's a cake without it?
(light music)
I went crazy and I got me all
these toys to make Twinkies.
But I'm gonna show you
how to turn that batter
into Twinkies without needing any of this.
If times are rough or you
simply like to save your bucks,
get a container like
any one of these tubes.
Just go and grab that forgotten
potato in your kitchen.
Grab some aluminum foil and
then mold it like a Twinkie
using the potato or one of the containers.
No worries, I'm including
detailed instructions
in the description.
This will take 15 minutes
to bake, not a lot.
The results, I mean, you
get what you pay for, man.
(dramatic horror music)
If Twinkies were born with
the fleshy look and wrinkles,
that's what you just got.
(sad trumpet sound)
(upbeat jazzy music)
First up, the Twinkie maker.
Yep, this actually exists.
And if you have about
$30 to spend, it's yours.
Perfect if you have no access to an oven.
Best part?
You get bouncy cakes
in about seven minutes.
(upbeat jazzy music)
The results?
If a Twinkie was a millennial girl
who overuses photo
editing on social media,
this would be it.
If you do have an oven, then
you can get baking molds.
Eight to $15 is gonna give
you a variety of options.
It takes 13 minutes to
bake and you're done.
And the result is incredibly
similar to an actual Twinkie.
(upbeat jazzy music)
I'm moving forward with
this normal-looking Twinkie,
but you can go ahead
and pick your favorite.
(light music)
You can cheat it like me and
grab some marshmallow fluff,
add a little bit of milk
to make it more manageable,
and move on.
If a Twinkie doesn't have
the classic three holes,
that thing is not a Twinkie.
So we gotta get them for
our homemade version.
Be firm and keep a steady flow.
You shouldn't have to wonder
where the cream filling
is if you did it right.
And you're done.
And now for the store version obviously.
Here's the fluffy,
classic, nostalgic cake.
These are, of course, the fluffy treats
with cream filling that you grew up with.
(bright music)
Let's break this down,
in terms of price the
store bought version wins.
Texture-wise, guys the
store bought version
is very fluffy, very soft,
but the homemade version is
extra fluffy, extra soft.
Preparation-wise, look.
It can get a little tiring,
especially if you have
little arms like mine,
but once you move on from that stage
and you see that batter
becoming the very version
of such a classic cake?
Guys, priceless.
What's life after that?
I have to add customization
as a category here,
because the Twinkie does
lend itself to that.
Some people cover it in chocolate,
some people add extra fillings,
but the homemade version, look.
I went a little crazy, as always,
and made some with chocolate,
made colorful ones.
Flavor, I asked six
people around the office
and four out of those
six said that they go
for the homemade version.
I have to agree.
When you bite into one of
these homemade versions,
you feel the shy presence
of sugar and eggs
because everything's
blend really, really well.
It's just the definition
of harmony in food.
That's what I'm talking about.
Boom, boom, boom.
(dramatic music)